[Music]
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's new favorite
podcast
this is ru garbage I'm your host H Foley
self-proclaimed suburban Philly garbage
and sitting directly across a dumpster
here's my illustrious co-host who is
from a long line of purebred Northeast
Philly trash and they're like ticks baby
that's right a lot of blue-collar jobs
coming out of his lot of no-show jobs -
clearly garbage walking landfill four
hours ago to text me are you ready to do
my podcast in four hours like a buddy
them up I'm drinking coffee I'm reading
the paper and then you you come in late
to your podcast garbage trash trash late
first time I have ever been late to
anything involving comedy in 11 years
you're trash the MTA [ __ ] them yeah the
MTA it's not that you probably fell
asleep and woke up at 11:30 was it oh
[ __ ] out of coma these trains they go up
they go down buddy get up get the hell
out there get under given us yep get on
the platform
I gotta get our program here that voice
you hear to my right is our illustrious
guest this week did I say a love story
is twice I'm garbage smart would I know
your word-of-the-day calendar from 1999
ladies we are so happy to have this
gentleman here he's a great friend of
ours
he's been on The Tonight Show he's been
on Conan he performs all over the
country all over the world ladies and
gentlemen mr. Nathan McEntee we did it
we got me in the building on time I
don't know how it happened I was on the
MTA - maybe they just liked me
you don't mean yeah the Train
I'm sorry you also probably took the
same train or no I take a separate train
look I'm one of the people you don't I
mean there's a separate train when
you're one of the people everywhere and
the driver does come out and he goes
look everybody
you're upper-class yeah yeah clearly
decent people that work will get you to
where you want to go on time we're gonna
get that guy that yes it's eatin ice
cream in February on the on the platform
he's gonna be late just not the TV see
that guy who's sweating in February he's
gonna he's gonna be late to his
appointment it's hot out there I mean
it's muggy it is this is not winter good
boys I'm happy to be here thank you guys
for having me
so health heroes big fans we're so happy
to have you here real sorry real quick I
just wanna say to the listener rate
review and subscribe on iTunes get that
out of the way real quick listen to me
[ __ ] bozos all right we gotta get
this plane off the ground third attempt
to [ __ ] successful and I ain't going
back to [ __ ] waiting tables I'll tell
you that right now
so you take your chubby little fingers
on up and hit the [ __ ] subscribe
button tell the [ __ ] friend rate and
review two goddamn thing let's keep this
thing [ __ ] moving and if you got to
youtube there on your internet service
subscribe on YouTube you can watch us
and subscribe to us and follow us on
Instagram and Twitter relax
let's get into it okay let's get into it
Nathan you're here to find out if you
are garbage okay so we're gonna sit
we're gonna goof around a little bit
we're gonna talk we're gonna have some
laughs whatever you want play a little
game sound good yeah man I'm already
here haha man I was like no at this
point I'm no neither you've run it by me
I don't want to be here anymore I'm not
gonna do with this we could just go get
some omelets
depends my offering or what it's hernia
imaged that because that was something
you know I was thinking we should call
we should call garbage confessions of
the week we should say things that we
did that was garbage to started off and
I got a couple from today possible yeah
late now to stop at the late I'm late
once I mean you're also I
you're an idiot if they want to believe
that you've been late for one thing ever
in your life in 11 years in comedy I'm
always 10 minutes early so you must been
stabbed then robbed something crazy
happen out there if you've never been
late in your life Nate I don't want to
call myself a hero but there's some
blind children that come out of a fire
safely about 25 what gay gun club glass
is that by the way those rose-colored
shooters just got a Cadillac bumpers on
it relax I was telling the Kip here it's
uh it's dark outside sometimes you want
some color in your life and then these
glasses sitting around there actually
Liz's but I told her to buy them because
I wanted to wear them I have some
underwear of my girlfriends that same
thing happened later all right so what
do you got there tub see what do I got
it said that and yes I am garbage
because that is a serious question when
you ask me what do I get an omelet or
somebody asks me what do I get for
breakfast it is a situation where it
depends who I'm with you don't I mean if
I'm by myself you would be really you
would be sad I think he's like Denzel
and a man on fire or five [ __ ] this man
on fire think about the pain as mass
just recently watch that that's a good
man on fire Dakota Fanning man that
kid's got some chops for a nine-year-old
okay that she's good real good so what
are you getting out again get back to
your dream breakfast if you have a dream
breakfast you're by yourself you get you
get a disgusting amount of food and all
by myself he gets a burrito if I'm now
listen I want to preface this all right
me and my girlfriend we were doing plant
base for like two and a half weeks is
that true yes that's true I've been
doing it for like three months I'm down
about six all right you know if the one
up me know I'm on the same stuff we
treated ourselves a little Chinese on
son
they had fish last night I was with you
yeah all right wait fish fish look I get
what you're saying about the fish I've
had fish three weeks in here he already
got him twice that he's not doing a
plant face Chinese food is he eating
more salad maybe I mean it's not a
plant-based [ __ ] diet all right relax
jillian Barberie what's going on shut
the [ __ ] up he's wearing glasses like
this and that movie
yeah backseat the guy we use like what
kind of Ford you get the fish you just
walked in the store go I want a fish so
what'd you get this I'm gonna fish a
burrito Chinese food this is all general
Tao cheddar omelet well you know it's
you know it's trash if you're ordering
delivery if your first meal today is
delivery and it's not breakfast like you
get you get sometimes you'll get like
Chinese food for breakfast when you wake
up I used to in the past yes yes that's
true yeah classy operation right there
wait God let me get some [ __ ] egg
rolls like Doug like the coal out my
eyes all right you won't get a dim sum
yeah I took a little time off this
summer I relaxed a little bit so two and
a half weeks plant-based plant pace okay
good and you're feeling good I'm feeling
good I like the hair like the glasses
thank you but I slipped up this morning
and will happen on the business end of
an eggo waffle a little thing called a
full bottle of whiskey I ate a whole cow
no I got to move the car that's why
that's why I called you and lined it up
over at the Mickey D's drive-through why
won't you call me I mean you couldn't
you don't mean why didn't you go hey
buddy phone a friend you're up the
suicide hotline it's a [ __ ] Egg
McMuffin are you in my ops and get me in
the car with you we'll both run through
the drive-thru oh I love a sausage
muffin and I haven't had one in so long
but a sausage with muffin no egg cheese
[Music]
great the salt that's also a dollar
fifty buddy it's a party you can get two
of those I spent six bucks
this is [ __ ] egg the egg doesn't even
the eggs not really I don't trust their
eggs
it is a real egg that's what they say I
don't buy
I've seen them crack a meeting used to
have a little ring the 90s was wide open
no but it was they bring these we don't
know what they were putting [ __ ] it was
like a Wild West back there it was like
it was like a couple of napkins and they
painted the middle yellow and they
there's no way they use in real eggs I
don't care look I'm in McDonald's fan in
terms of like MIT cafes a party you like
their coffee no poke at 99 cents all day
oh and that's the door and it's good
that's trash Mik Cafe is a party I don't
call it Mickey I don't try to church it
up I don't call me I don't go let me get
a make cafe st. gonna table when you go
in to smoke and I get a Mick Cafe I'm
saying the coffee has do you understand
yeah I can't wait till one of us flips
this table so anyway if you would have
called the you texted me at 8:30 in the
morning right I was up okay okay you
said but you really read in the paper I
was reading the paper hasn't written got
no number in the paper no I uh
a little grapefruit you know what I mean
actually I'll get the juice we're
talking with this club I drink black
coffee I know I seen the Instagram
stories at the French press and all that
stuff years ago hey thanks man you
remember these things yeah of course so
anyways if you would have been like
buddy look we're both up I'm going to
McDonald's what's a private thing okay
that's like jerking off to me I don't
want anybody to see it no more looks
like you took all five times a day then
pal I'm embarrassed by so what did you
guess I'm you know what did you get from
McDonald's will happen I got a sausage
egg sausage egg McMuffin and then I get
a hash brown and I put the hash brown on
top of the egg sausage Egg McMuffin and
then I got a McGriddle Oh with bacon and
ham had them deep-fry that shove it up
my ass and two whole milks
I can't even I stopped I went to a
diabetic coma that's the truth rude all
right but this also let's put a pin in
that we'll get right back to eat
definitely if I'm garbage
he's definitely passed out for three
hours and woke up late that's why I did
not sleep I got on a train at the right
time then I went for a job was doing
shoot at the house whatever
well either way I've never I've never
had myself the McGriddle
never had it I know rides too it's too
much I know it's got the syrup in the
bread right it's got the syrup in
it's a pancake Nathan but basically
right it's it's like yeah I've never had
it when it came out I mean I was like yo
this is this is when I was basically it
stopped drinking I remember the
McGriddle came out and I was like man if
this had come out when I was drink
drinking I would have been bad oh are
you kidding me I want to walk right in
there and I've been like I'm a gay gun
owner give McGriddle don't look at me
what the tapes in a bag - let's go move
it I want you to empty out the security
cameras because nobody's gonna see this
thing anyways I remember at the time I
was like he'll McGriddle they seemed
like a part of the rover had one it's a
good time have you ever had the McRib no
I know I'm trash because you guys your
family has it on Christmas don't ya give
it to each other that Christmas I got
you three mcribs
I got you three we quit we'll just work
that in our favor
better sorting them which one feels
heavier all the ones you give out of a
bite I'm addicted to fast food so I know
I know I'm [ __ ] I'm trash I was at
one point time yeah yeah really what up
there you do your Tim Hortons guy right
no I considered fast food now it is yeah
at one point I'm at one point ton well
now they have components I'm linens on
the tables and so that's one point I'm I
mean one point in time you needed you
needed to talks to get into their
smoking area if you wanted to walk in
there and eat cigarettes while drink
coffee you needed to look a certain
assertion or a they used to just
Sunday's best Sunday's best so you
should just be straight up coffee and
baked goods and then they became I mean
you can get chilly in there now you can
get and get whatever yeah yeah so it is
now I think now you could consider it
fast food but at one point time but I
was uh I was a McDonald's guy for sure
you have a big extra [ __ ] I used to
pound those the big extra was it was a
little bit bigger of a stood on his arm
I wish I know if you had the big extra
tent in your home I'd be like what a
hero yeah the big extra it was like a
little bit bigger of a patty and they
put this seasoning salt on it yo no I'll
say I might have been a regional thing
with this seasoning salt cuz I found
that different
nathan's of Canadian comedian just
everybody knows out there grew up north
there Toronto Canada no Nova Scotia man
Nova Scotia and know speaking of local
things Nova Scotia has the McLobster the
big Bluebird lobster the McLobster real
thing
Wow not [ __ ] with you there's a fried
saw year-round it's no no just like a
certain stage giving Canadian
Thanksgiving Canadian Easter Christmas
they have thrown a week apart my
birthday they it's it's a little it's a
it's a it's a lobster roll right here ok
that's what the double wrap slow roll
but that's what they give that's what
the middle and they give you you won't
talk you won't talk trash they give you
a little bit that has a lobster on it
which the sandwich party that's garbage
but that's a party is that not a fun
time you go and get a lot of smoke and
get a little kick kicking a crab into
the sea crab kick he's gonna he's gonna
union delegate have a hard hey what the
[ __ ] you lookin at jerk-off eat my
goddamn roll move on but anyways yeah
have you tried it
me no no my mom used to pound these
though really how'd she like can you go
down to this can you go down a
McDonald's get me a big lobster this is
a this is a did you know this is a
little deeper did you know you were
garbage when you were growing up no see
I don't think you're not garbage now
yeah you and your very adamant about not
being garbage you have a very you live
by a very strict set of rules that
prevent you from navigating back into
garbage oh yeah you're running from
something nobody wears pink sunglasses
mister hiding the dark or every fence
you jump it's been dark for 72 days in
New York and maybe just want a little
color in your life you know you're
always she always dresses fresh always
looks nice I bet knew his apartment his
apartments neat clean organized he
always carries themselves very well he
hates garbage sorry cuz he always calls
it out when somebody does something
trashy can't stand well let me tell you
okay you want you want to get like kind
of serious here the we turn the lights
out
no he's the the being late thing right
and where I'm off it you do whatever you
want you don't I mean if you want to I'm
still you to acknowledge and I'm never
late I'm sorry I was late it's fine that
you're late I'm late you guys go
in your folder for sure I seriously do
not care this is my thought on this i
UCL a my roommate about this because we
we were he live right across the hall
from me in the apartment years ago right
I went both we were writing on we were
trying to write some [ __ ] thing sure
we were like 10 a.m. we're gonna leave
here go to the library rent like a
little conference room sort of like jail
and we're gonna write understand I'd be
out there at 9:45 yeah coffee done
whatever I hear him [ __ ] bumbling
like mr. beating in his goddamn rooms
got a bucket on his head you know a mop
in his [ __ ] he he'd come out 10:15
he'd be like alright let's go I go what
the [ __ ] what happened and he's like
it's 10:15 we time I go look man if you
had a job sir and you had to be there at
10:00 would you not be there at 10:00
yeah and he's like well you're getting
paid for that I go yeah okay do you not
want to be paid for this you know you're
in [ __ ] [ __ ] not talk about you
I've got a [ __ ] show up to things
you're taking it I'm talking in general
in Jennings I got a McGriddle in here
I'll take a riddlin zombies insulin oh
[ __ ] you are garbage can we get a big
breakfast take the edge off a little bit
can somebody say Ritalin and Aerosmith
Tickets okay back to the festival real
quick and then we ask me any questions
you want to do with so big extra I loved
we also have an in Nova Scotia these
things called donators which is like
it's like a gyro but we got our own
sauce trash sauce okay it's delicious
though but it's like yo they okay it's
canned milk yeah sugar
well don't yeah yeah and I know it what
I know what I don't vinegar no but this
is like this special donair sauce that
only these coasts makes okay can milk
sugar it's sweet sauce on meat well what
thank God wait what sweet sauce on a
meat and and a my blood orange I got the
chills look hurt on that like don't air
meat like a gyro meat like that like
lamb that the shaped lamb I love it but
uh but I grew up with it but also he's I
used to do Wendy's okay you guys Wendy's
famed here why he's fair what am i a
[ __ ] jerk-off okay this confirmation
Wendy's spicy chicken sandwich sure okay
I'm familiar name okay and you get the
you ask them to give you the cheese that
they use for the baked potato the lil G
Oh buddy you put that on top of the
spicy chicken sandwich let me tell you
something that is a guys what are we you
know you know what are we talking about
get a couple hefty bags in here to get
him out of here that's that's a true
sign of garbage and I do the same thing
cuz I feel good good I usually customize
my holders at McDonald's because I want
I want to know what's fresh in toilet
like it having so multiple burgers
together
double cheeseburger no pickles no
ketchup extra onions and Mac sauce
nothing in there's fresh you know what I
mean they're both there put it they
don't have one of them sitting back
there they gotta make I go okay now I
hear what you're saying you're like if
you order something so specific specific
specific they gotta yeah oh that's like
if that's another [ __ ] [ __ ] move
to is the the let me get fries without
salt because then they have move make
them Brown yes that's it's like yeah
that's a [ __ ] jerk because they can't
even use the tray anymore now they gonna
basically put it in their hand burning
third degrees you ever see some piece of
[ __ ] just given the guys the people
behind the counter in fast-food places
like just just being awful to them I
never do that even if something that's
[ __ ] up and saying I knew what I was
getting into when I walked in this joint
yeah sure I know in my Mercedes
dealership this lady when popeyes
chicken sandwich came out I had to try
it and the [ __ ] place was packed and
this [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] is in I
didn't send you a preview they didn't
mail you want a week ahead of time I
gotta screw it we gotta get the big guy
in Queenie in the influencers we had
them out there getting their sandwiches
well I mean the fat the Furious is what
it would be in furious furious
anyway this lady was bitching that
bitching at the guy he's fries fresh and
she made she made him give a real accent
on that but a real accent does it okay
so the way it was gives gives
makes makes him give heard the fryer so
she can taste
that's what that is why I'm gonna prove
that's [ __ ] garbage
it's wild be are these fries fresh did
you ever know they're not fresh not a
[ __ ] Cabernet you don't get the
[ __ ] taste a little dryer you can
pretty hear it rumble in the box
did you ever did you ever work at a fast
new place
no never a fast food no yeah you did I
did I worked at AMW in u4w
like a couple they have a couple of
stands I'm really shitty mall well they
have our dogs it seemed they'll be
rooting a bunch evolution they out there
they're one of their catalyzes a hot dog
yeah what do they call that you know I
don't know called a whistle dogs bro
hello cheese and bacon that things apart
yeah I've had him oh I've had him in the
shamon team all shout out to the shiny
mall [ __ ] probably even 2001 they did
for like a week and everything but the
[ __ ] is this corny Canadian [ __ ] yeah
but I'll be with a brick and mortar take
I they were they worth a lot of root
beer floats to a lot of root beer floats
and they get they got a delicious
[ __ ] burger I'm not gonna [ __ ] I'm
not aligned you yeah that's Dairy Queen
is knows their way around a burger no no
dear Queens burgers absolutely I don't
eat it anything's you know what thing do
you have that's good i body is a temple
mate do you know what they do have that
at burger I'm not sorry Dairy Queen
that's a good that [ __ ] fry basket the
chicken strip basket you know I'm
talking about comes with Texas toast and
gravy telling me you know what I'm
talking about hard to [ __ ] up a
challenger is it that's thank you [ __ ]
I'm not saying you can't say it's
impossible
no Mike dumbass mom but these are good
chicken two years here with a whistle
dog these on taking them off of a good
time you know very very food heavy this
episode that shows were garbage yeah
well I mean you two just went off on
[ __ ] each have your own opinion like
you were given the State of the Union on
each each [ __ ] fast dude right you've
never had that you've never had the
chicken strip basket from his wedding
what are you talking about
I'm also big french fry in milkshake guy
I've done that yeah I've done that funny
a front fry I'll tell you this
McDonald's fries in their [ __ ] ice
cream oh yeah when the machines work to
keep these ice cream back in to none
it's a party the only the only the only
place that you could can't even rival it
is Dairy Queen and McFlurry I'd say I'd
say a blizzard is better than a McFlurry
but both are rock-solid [ __ ]
investments good grades I had I had a
thing this weekend where I was I'm very
I'm very like you I'm very I have rules
that like you know let you're early
you're late it's like very it's very
strict in my head Pacino an Irishman
yeah exactly so exactly so I went out to
I went out to brunch with a group of
friends that are in from town for
everything for they were here for the
wedding and got married this we America
know it all some people might think
that's coach I love it the whole idea to
spend seven hundred million dollars for
[ __ ] who for [ __ ] watch you know
what I mean look how it's not dropping
back one day oh it's kids smart what is
money yeah talking about those come on
man he goes up looking at you got the
barrel buddy what the [ __ ] are you doing
yeah what do you got in the bank what
happened a [ __ ] hard cash what
happened with liquid manifest I just
bored she would we're in Hawaii for
[ __ ] Christmas
I'm going down to Miami for a couple of
days I'm laying out over here kids at
the podcaster do his nose wide open ten
what happened that's it what I asked you
directly what yeah I guess you did no no
first of all we came back this Bronx
then I gotta know why you're going to
Miami but yes you did he's gonna watch a
doctor New York Comedy Club this Cantina
fits up and he goes like this he does so
what do you what do you what do
what do you got buddy mean what am i got
you know in the bank he's like he
probably got what he would he got 67 he
looks like a guy that saves his money I
respect that that's all yeah I can tell
plus you don't booze a lot you're out
there you know who's you don't eat out
you know not really no you bring snacks
with the I see with your all I need but
that but that's that diet medical
condition Dietary that's a medical
condition I don't know get a medical no
I don't really have a medical condition
but if I my blood sugar will just
[ __ ] drop and I just do this I always
have to have some kind of I have a tree
candy one day it'll be hard candy you
know like an old man has Werther's yeah
I'll have all have bags of those on me
you know I mean wrong orders out of a
cardigan pocket you know it's pretty
good to a nip yeah even though we can't
say that just day and age it's called
coronavirus it's the little caramel
candy you know I'm talking about how do
they not have and maybe it's maybe it's
because it's too old
what about a Werther's McFlurry no
that's for like seven people I know but
but right I mean a Werther you grind
that up you get the Werther's I'm in I'm
in Werther's McFlurry get me all the way
to look I've watched two episodes of
make millions get me to the top I want
to talk to these people
Werther's Mick Foley gonna happen how
many when you go into McDonald's who's
just sitting around day time it is all
people Janerio this was they got they
got a coffee from [ __ ] yesterday
sitting there with the legs crossed you
don't and another guy they wish they
could smoke they can't cuz the [ __ ]
you know no one you could smoke the
little tin foil the little are you
aluminum ash trays they had of the
McDonald
yes the little smoking areas oh I used
to get sad when I see there's such a we
run out of chicken nuggets
when you what is it down the slide at
the play place with a monkey bars would
burn what else give me one more one more
I'm gas Girma stop sucking you grimace
is a great name and I also love just a
purple teardrop what the [ __ ] is he
he's a nugget no the thing he's a nugget
somebody supposed to be a purple nugget
he's a bad nugget Rosa nugget he might
be a bad nugget always not cuz he was
around before the Nuggets even came out
that's probably I remember when the
Nuggets dropped my life it was a
thriller he lives his life into two eras
pre nugget and post nugget BN and Zn the
Bedini album came out nuggets I used to
not be able to eat at McDonald's in
there when the old guys are in there cuz
I felt safe there was like one old guy
sitting by himself he had nobody left
and like that small like that was his
lunch for the day mm-hmm and it had to
be perfect and it probably wasn't always
perfect and he was sitting there sad
eating the burger that he didn't really
want tricking his coffee wouldn't no one
to talk yeah but now looking back now do
you get older that guy was probably
[ __ ] just happy as a peach he might no
one bother him he's got his [ __ ]
burger he's got a cup of coffee
coffee's whew laughs Mary seem sad how
about this how about this give that guy
a [ __ ] Werther's McFlurry you know
others McFlurry you act like I'm the guy
stopping these people from havin where
there's McFlurry somebody's [ __ ]
stopped and they're not in there I don't
[ __ ] see him in there get him in there
I like the idea Thanks I'm into what
happened this brother might happen what
could you invest in the McFlurry
if I got two people together what's a
liquid that's what I want to know when
you have this afternoon in the room
right and be like look most of your here
here's here's your here's your this is
your audience drunks also you know they
know I mean no they don't they don't
didn't give up they made the McDermott
cafe solely kind of for this right but
they're really just trying to compete
with [ __ ] now yeah they were making
that for the old dirt I don't but I know
but for the old people anybody that's
not true doesn't care so McDonald actual
McDonald's doesn't care head office yeah
they don't head office gives a [ __ ] now
they sit around and they try to figure
out how can we [ __ ] put more nuggets
into people yeah sorry one hip grab
young herbage you ever hear Jerry here
with a guy said he was the owner he goes
I don't I'm not in the hamburger
business I'm in the real estate business
yeah yeah yeah all saw the founder okay
and that was 50 years ago we're talking
about the marketing the brand recently
bro okay but here's what they've done
they understand that the drunk people go
in there they know that sure they know
the teams go in there sure they know
that kids want to be everybody but but
but what they're not what they're
[ __ ] missing out on is the old what
do you want me to call on my gotcha
I'm on board with yeah I said it with
Adam on the horn mate I bet you I spent
more money in McDonald's in every old
person that's ever eaten at McDonald's
since it opened they go when they get a
cup of call I'm not gonna fight with you
on that
it's a cafe okay let's get it right what
happened at this brunch so I'm very uh
considerate of the people around me I
tend to be you know and I feel I feel
that people are not considerate in a row
at a restaurant that's a [ __ ] trashy
move I feel like you weren't raised
right your night you're not being
consider people's people's space I guess
I'm yeah and a big one for me
is uh you know anywheres facetiming in
public oh yeah it's fine
have you ever done it no I don't face
time period but any time I do see
somebody face time without headphones
you grow up
I know grow the [ __ ] I know I'm not your
house dude I was at we're at this brunch
and there's like 15 of us which is
already too much for me my anxiety's
guides to this guy don't wait let's
order this guy doesn't know what he
wants this guy has asking for this on
the site it's too [ __ ] good don't
like tight spaces and love noises no he
put 14 here Oh give me an open field in
a [ __ ] 360-degree field of vision I'm
in chef your helmet on what about a gun
that shoots confetti
yeah but then somebody they start
FaceTime and they're passing it around
the tables dust to every mic my group
discussing my crew and I'm like holy
[ __ ] yeah I'm the [ __ ] piece of trash
in this restaurant
who was on the phone there was a baby
who can't even understand oh you're
showing a babe where was the baby in
Germany a German baby German baby hmm I
mean this makes a little bit more sense
yeah German baby II Germany I mean
that's a whole but everybody who is from
Germany yeah but they're not in Germany
currently I know but the baby can't talk
to maybe just make noises you're not
even gaining anything yeah from the calm
but you're seeing a baby that you're
probably not gonna see I get what you're
saying again we're passing it around the
eye to get up and leave I wouldn't have
I get what you're saying I called a some
out front oh my god well I gotta [ __ ]
blow this one out you weren't that you
weren't that guy in that situation if
it's it hey I get a little you get
listen you get a little bit of a pet I
know what you're saying you get a little
bit of a pass when you're a large group
celebrating something
now I'm directing like [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's annoying
and my book that was an [ __ ] move
you're already invade in the space is a
15-person in a restaurant that holds 40
15 people 15 person I can't I get what
you're saying but again if you if you
you know this is a baby from over
citizen overseas babies a German baby
you don't see that at all Germans in
Germany there's not a big wheel in the
restaurant our German you have a baby
the [ __ ] you know about a baby German
baby look like they have Russian baby
head in the back now no they don't
you know Russian baby head no I think it
is like a flat head in the back you know
baby sometimes their flat heads sure
it's a visual bed it's a visual bed you
got to see when I go that guy's got
Russian baby head and then it makes
sense I think we should happen to the
game here gang as I said before ladies
and gentlemen our guest today is mr.
Nathan McIntosh some of his credits
include the Conan O'Brien show the
tonight class Jimmy Fallon already forms
all over you've got a couple of Canadian
television shows what's that one mr.
Jeezy what's it called mr. Jeezy is that
it where Young Jeezy
moves Canada and gets a job at a
Harvey's Jerry these mr. d mr. d yeah
very funny
yeah um forms all over the place okay
before us regularly in New York City but
we're here to find out is he garbage you
have a lot of aunts and uncles or you uh
think your family this isn't part of our
how much what are you got in here right
now
tell me that 20 bucks how much got a
briquette cash future what's going on
the rapper anyways I got you thank you I
didn't know this guy but this is really
good really good learning I can talk to
the future
[Laughter]
credit card debit card a couple bucks in
there you know I mean look at that one
that's a one dollar bill and it's all
fifty not gonna lie really I think how
many aunts and uncles I have what he
means how makes my family yeah I mean
they have a little family that's all man
little let's say little family little
family there's people up there but
people don't talk to them you know I'm
sure and you've her brother correct I
got a brother yeah he just turned
birthday happy birthday yeah happy
birthday brother
what do you turn a birthday Jeezy what
do you turn 32 how much money does he
have big dog bark you know what I mean
200 dollars to my name I'm uh I'm older
than him yeah all right younger brother
yeah okay Nathan
now we've tailored the game a little bit
towards your great you're Canadian
handicap perfect uh Kevin you want to
start it off yes this is all this is all
this I written this prior to uh you guys
have different question yeah yeah the
last conversation does anyone in your
family play with McDonald's Monopoly
game it doesn't exist anymore but when
it did exist I think so I think I've
ever yeah I'll say yes absolutely yes
yeah you DS episode buddy [ __ ] dude
[Laughter]
nation you got the [ __ ] board out you
can win a fries there's grease all over
your fingers you know I knew a kid who
knew a kid this is old fat guy lor I
knew a guy who knew a guy I knew a kid
who knew a kid that never works I hung
out with this King unwrapped the quarter
pounder it was a full pound his dad his
dad owned a McDonald's and he gave him
the inside scoop mm-hmm there is no
boardwalk or there is no Park Place it's
all a setup
mm-hmm coming back yeah are they put we
got us where look they put like one
that's a good time they put one you have
not seen make millions yet no it's on
HBO I haven't watched millions about
this about the scam of the McDonald's
Monopoly game game yeah it's really good
yeah the mob buddy yeah that's me one
more time the answer might change
quarter yes seriously seriously he need
something he's bought out bah-bah-bah he
needs it
kippis eyebrows so ya know there was a
McDonald's Monopoly also follow-up
question did anybody ever collect like
the toys that they gave out of the Happy
Meals like to collect their horse oh
elected him wait a shot them they played
with them let me tell you what we had
you have like you know were they the hey
don't touch them that's my [ __ ] know
we didn't like woody not the toy aspect
the only time we did have oh the [ __ ]
Batman Forever glasses oh the places
zeroes the engraved glass you know got
the [ __ ] Riddler on the side he got
to face I wanted all of those you got
movie [ __ ] stemware your [ __ ] trash
I was 10 years old I wanted the goddamn
cop you got merchandise [ __ ] cutlery
hit the bricks you are Thanksgiving
dinner on Superman plates no I know what
he's talking about
can you pass the bowl you know that we
had the we had the Olympic mugs that
they that they gave out in the eighties
and [ __ ] fest they also had a line
they have like they would give out a
glasses I like with like and the grey
we're down in the dishwasher and become
like but that was a good glass you put
some iced tea in that day scream Batman
for everyone's didn't have they were
just glass they didn't have any painter
they were [ __ ] I know also too you
know we used to collect when it came out
but it was a big indicator oh [ __ ]
trash you might not understand cuz
you're Canadian look at when the state
quarters came out buddy look at that
that was big in our family get it weird
Oh grab a water or something would you
look at the car I just want to see if it
was it I was away was it the way I
remember
I think they only sold it and you're a
year McDonald no I'm just saying it's
just the way that I really members but
first of all that guy selling on ebay so
you know that's worth a couple of bucks
your uncle worth 60 or 70 can afford
this the state quarters you don't
remember that one like hippies in the
trash gone out and bought like yeah they
only have released like two one three
like but she had a map of the US and
like put each one in it well not what
she thought that was gonna be like our
college fund wait till this all wait
till this hits that's like meeting was
worth six bucks money it wasn't even
worth its weight in quarters remember
everybody had beanie babies anybody was
gonna be worthy [ __ ] we had savings
bonds zero savings bonds during World
War two what are you talking about D
bills that was big in my day rations I
was like it they made it sound like all
I had to do was like wait 50 years and
cashed those savings bonds in and I was
uneasy amazed like seventeen I think we
can say when I was in like third grade
[ __ ] was there with James J Braddock
beat Max Baer savings bonds something
really trashy we did in the we did Hands
Across America are you too young to
remember that I did that with your mom
all right what else you got I haven't
asked a question yet like I said I
wanted to say before I've been I've been
doing something pretty trashy I've been
taking scam calls a lot lately almost
every time they call I asking for a job
but I'll be gonna be late but I'll be
there Nishi question what do you make
6070 what are you pulling down over
there no I bring him in like [ __ ] you
[ __ ]
and they always
you're cursed out by you do them one of
those things I'll tell you you know
that's not trashy that's like that's
like yeah that's psychotic that's
somebody who needs a friend that's what
that is
call me next time all right I'm in a
story yeah yeah fair enough
um all right let's see here have you
ever ran out onto the field during a
sporting event no have any your family
have any of your family cars ever had
wood paneling has your family ever owned
a car we've slept
does that count um wood paneling you
know you know the woodpecker's I do I'm
thinking the wind star I know the did
the Dodge witnessed our Chrysler [ __ ]
that price the wind star that's what it
was three who buy four is all over that
mean the [ __ ] when they come to the
Hacksaw Jim Duggan coming down the road
back in the day here the Ryan's back in
the day you were rich if you that was in
2004 we know I don't know I don't think
so
what some [ __ ] cars though yeah my mom
one time we were driving uh she had a
Chevy Blazer
Oh Blazers were nice for like a week and
a half these and this beat-up [ __ ]
and but shadows ladies always got
crunched up they see every place that
you saw hat listen a bumper that was in
[ __ ] a trash bag for a window I never
drove it I was a kid but I didn't look
first of my mom's a tiny little woman I
had a high center of gravity and I think
I think I don't know if you can see a
lot of stuff so I think you're just like
I'm coming in and you're just nice close
your eyes and hope for them hopefully
they see it a blazer shifting like I'm
in one time don't were speeding down the
road every Blazer was crunched up yes
every made a dent like it was like a
Bronco it was like a trash Bronco yeah
it was a poor man's brother it's like if
you can't afford to be OJ why do you be
one of these other fourth string players
you don't never heard of semi-pro OJ no
place I can one-up that for a little
while we had a GMC Jimmy I'm not gonna
go to the box of slim jim but my mom one
time drive the blood the Blazer I'm
speeding down the road she's like [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] just screaming [ __ ]
ran out of gas and then we're just
sitting there in the southern I'll meet
my brother and we didn't want to say
anything to her she's a psycho she's
[ __ ] scream it so she's just like Fox
so she she waves somebody down and then
says - he ended up calling somebody and
we waited for a tow truck we were there
for a while anyways the guy goes so what
happened she goes my mom goes well I was
low on gas so I figured I'd outrun the
gas she's like I figured I might sped I
went faster quicker yeah I seeked at the
time yes you're gonna run out again
minutes the guy goes you're burning gas
quicker breaking your mom's balls on
people in the 90s hey what are you dumb
broad what do you got a blazer with no
gas what you doing later
Oh Melrose Place again these two kids no
dad who these guys you know so serious
with the right head in the back what's
the other one watch what's going on here
pretty tight weird one doing how much
money I Foley go all right I got one has
your mama I got one and then a follow-up
to that as well has your mom ever cut
your hair that's not a no I don't think
I'm trying to think I'd have to be like
when I was real real young sure not like
a baby that's whatever yeah yeah I don't
I don't know man I don't remember that I
remember she let our hair girl want to
there's a picture made my brother
basically like you know just we're
standing on a rock and Peggy's Cove with
a little lobster [ __ ] how's your
neighbor's backyard he's cold
there you go that's a couple basics that
was her [ __ ] mancave those things go
what was the name of your grocery store
growing up
IgA it was called like international
grocers industrial complex Suzie they
only take food stamps
IgA but knows my mom didn't let our hair
grow for a long time yeah let it grow
nobody in the family like what the [ __ ]
is going on with your gym we were like
you got to do something I was like Jim
Morrison
we used to regularly maintain each other
to keep pushing haircuts off like I
would shave the back of my brother's
neck that's garbage
my mom would trim over my ears bugs also
follow up have you ever had a rat tail
no I had one a little bit I did fry it
wasn't too bad my minute the work we're
cooking you don't I mean they were like
on the cusp of becoming the next thing
and then some [ __ ] guy you know I
remember just woke up what are we doing
it's disgusting to look at I do write my
like a mullet though I'm not I'm not
you're back in a lot of college rock
mullets now mullets is back for the
young yeah the 20s they're all rocking
champion feel I'm not a you have a nice
mullet
you cannot can we agree on this you're
gonna have a nice mullet you cannot have
a nice rat do it you can't do it what is
in the front brat tail enough run [ __ ]
in the back yeah in the back oh yeah
that's fine
that dudes [ __ ] plane by the mayor of
[ __ ] white trash will that's what
that is
I grown-up member one time my mom we
used to cut her hair with like just
clippers in the summer yeah on the and
the one time we were trying to be cool
and she put it she tried to put it
number one in the back my handling I'm
number one I do look like a [ __ ] yeah
look like that's the man jeah but not
look at the number one that's the type
of thing - that's like mom you know
you're getting me killed until you go to
school and the kid just [ __ ] claps
her in the back and then [ __ ] head in
a locker all cuz I thought I was numero
uno number what it was I was seven I was
a fat seven year old yeah number one
wasn't even the number one of my house
number eleven yeah this kid stinks ah
Nathan do you know what KD is Kraft
Dinner
yep yeah it's what they call it they
call macaroni and cheese Kraft Dinner
what carbage excuse me yeah it's not Mac
objection perfect your honor please
garbage the ya know Kraft Dinner is a
real it's a thing no in Canada like we
have macaroni and cheese but the
originals of Kraft Dinner kaput that's a
more proper thing it's a box called
Kraft Dinner gotcha and yeah ma'am least
- [ __ ] that that was I mean dude you get
a box of that you boil that up you
sprinkle that [ __ ] cheese on to it
you [ __ ] wait what's Kraft Dinner
what's in that that's I'm saying it's
it's macaroni and cheese but it's called
Kraft Dinner
Servilia it's for a nice for fancy
dinners you know what I mean fancy
dinner when you're when your uncle gets
out of gets off parole you know if we
stand with the big thing casserole when
I was a kid was chicken on a crumb
where'd you make it a [ __ ] dumpster
that's an Alec crumb it was like a hot
chicken dish no that's maybe it sounds
like a lawyer's like that what hey oh
[ __ ] he's coming in to end it checking
all the crumb you know the crumbs over
this is Kraft Dinner you [ __ ]
Kraft Dinner
that's macaroni and cheese that's like
it's like the difference between
Velveeta and Kraft it's the same [ __ ] no
it was called crap wait a second it
doesn't always been Kraft macaroni and
cheese and we call the Kraft Dinner yes
oh yeah yeah works right yeah I always
thought it was just called grab dinner I
thought if you looked at a box and said
Kraft Dinner but no Kraft
it's that okay yeah just say when I was
a kid ramen we used to call it elusive
noodles
yeah I remember yeah who does it as well
I think that was a brand doodles of
noodles was a brand at some point you've
stakin was when you were a kid
stinkums last week what are you talking
about North stay comes know just like
chopped-up meat illios pizza no wow have
you ever drank milk out of a bag yeah we
have bagged milk but that doesn't make
you're garbage
Canada does bag milk you say milk - you
say honey milk I don't say milk
I say milk that's my did not say milk
milk yeah milk no kind of a bag okay
Peggy steep that was a bed and breakfast
at Peggy's Cove
dinner and a bag of milk called add a
bag of milk honey we do bet not all of
them look we got the [ __ ] container
stupid Canada does
do canada's little backward eczema
backwards help me pull your mouth get a
bag I don't obey the milk and Canada's
probably better than the milk here and I
used to drink milk out of it that's
coming from a cow so you know it means
my cousin's up north a real uppity I
grew up around them you got a tight end
of it um have you ever run a George
Foreman grill
I loved me a George Foreman
I love the George Foreman yeah the
George Foreman grills apart there was
one in my old house my roommate had it
all right but I used to cook you put out
you put all you put anything in a
chicken breast chicken yeah I love a
George from you know the George Foreman
store at the story George Foreman yeah
yeah the grill yeah do you yeah I think
I'm supposed to go to a whole charisma
yes okay what am i [ __ ] jerk-off
I want you don't call your [ __ ] you
know I own the whole juicer to or
whatever he got out of the deal whatever
the Hulk got screwed on the day opened
uh they all thought of him
they offered it the Hulk Hogan first
yeah do you want the grill [ __ ] that
ain't gonna [ __ ] give me the pasta made
pasta mania yeah he opened a restaurant
called pasta mania he lost out like you
know fifty billion
Oh God all of it yeah he lost something
all those goddamn money impossible yeah
all right you got one Foley have you or
any member of your family have you or
any member of your family ever known Lee
went to an uncle cracker or Kid Rock
concert I don't think so
you were any member of my family cuz I
got a friend who's been a Kid Rock
concert
easily but no kid right friends good
Rock well III got a friend you should
meet it's called garbage it's garbage
man he's got about that guy first of all
I understand where Kid Rock has ended up
Kid Rock's got a couple good songs we
kid me Bob - Bob bang - bang diggy that
sounds great cowboy is a guy's a hot
rock in songs
Rocky's a good time he's garbage Cowboys
are great have you ever hung out on a
couch in a garage you know yeah I've
slept on a pull-out a garage I grew up
in a lot of apartments man how so we did
but I have I have hung out my friends my
friend we have hung out in storage room
something that
you don't mean so that's that's that's
that's it the equivalent of a garage
storage room yeah Wow also tell you
there's my mom prom that's how people
pronounce that they would say garage
garage when I talk to my mom she's like
she's your grandfather's out in the
garage
yeah have you or any female member of
your family ever flashed a security
guard to gain access to a concert or
live for four that's certainly the no
how involved is that question how
involved that's coming from were you
ever in an your mom ever blown anybody
in a rat I get to the main stage were
you ever in an episode of Family Matters
season 4 yeah we're rule is trying to
get pad like that's do you like ketchup
flavored potato chips you're just
talking you basically you're asking me
is are you Canadian are you Canadian yes
and listen I can tell by the look
someone on glasses he's Canadian buddy
have you ever had a ketchup chip yes
it's a [ __ ] fiesta right it's good
stuff thank you all right I got one have
you ever walked through a drive-thru
bringing it full circle gentlemen yeah
yeah that's a bad seat of your wall if
you're like trying to jump to register
that you're a go people have done it
that they had to put a sign up so it
can't be go reason that I did it was a
friend of mine worked there at night
never closed the front so it's even
worse all of me like buddy is Mike in
there
oh uh cus up on the [ __ ] Nuggets
though he'd give you like a bag like a
bag bag right it's a good friend right
there about full circle thank you
everybody for for listening as real
quick again please rate review and
subscribe follow us on Instagram yes
game everything that Nathan Macintosh
yes Nathan Macintosh calm Twitter
Instagram I got a podcast called
positive anger you listen to it on
everything
perfecto oh it's das you know I mean
listen we're getting this thing off the
ground so please it's very important you
guys written to view it like Kevin said
please subscribe to the YouTube channel
follow me on Twitter h-holy and eyes
follow me on instagram at folia grams
Kevin you already gave all your feminine
comedy across all platforms that's right
NH Folie calm we thank you guys so much
and we'll see you next week for another
exciting edition of are you garbage
am i garbage by the way oh you're trash
goodbye are you going back to Queens or
no yes directly